four years ago I survived one of the
worst natural disasters on record it was
January 12 2010 and I was in a meeting
with my colleagues in port-au-prince
Haiti when the walls of our building
started to shake scared and confused we
raced to the door only to realize that
the door was jammed shut we were trapped
when the shaking stopped we unjammed the
door and we raced down the stairs and as
I stepped over the threshold I was
welcomed by the outstretched arm of my
colleague and then I looked up and he
was covered in dust and white powder and
I started to look around in to my left
the cultural center vaporized the
primary school in the far corner
collapsed the building I had just come
out of was hanging by a thread and I
grasped the hand of my colleague and we
looked out onto the city that we called
home and it was barely recognizable the
next day I was completely overwhelmed by
what I saw collapsed homes and hospitals
family separated a country rocked to its
core I had this feeling of knots in my
stomach I wanted to do something but the
problem seems so much bigger than me and
I didn't know where to start I felt
hopeless
in that same moment on the other side of
town my colleague Paul was emerging from
the rubble of his collapsed four-story
building and instead of succumbing to
the feeling of helplessness that I felt
he was compelled to take action and
that's what I want to talk to you about
today I learned a profound lesson from
Paul that day it's about what I can do
and what you can do in the face of
overwhelming challenges Paul was a 24
year old I worked with me at the
microfinance bank I worked at in Haiti
he joined our organization because he
was really passionate about our mission
to deliver financial and educational
resources to some of the most vulnerable
communities in Haiti he had been quite
successful and had been known for
developing a really strong relationship
with his clients Paul was in his
apartment building when the earthquake
hit that day and collapsed with him
inside for 24 hours he was trapped
beneath the rubble of his home until his
neighbors came to dig him out in that
moment Paul had a choice he could have
let the situation overwhelm and paralyze
him but instead injured and dehydrated
he took a stick and he started walking
and step by step he walked to the home
of his first client to see if they were
okay and then he walked to the home of a
second client and then the third and
then the fourth and over and over step
by step door by door house by house Paul
went to check on each and every one of
his client
to see if they were okay the steps Paul
took that day had a huge impact for
months stories rolled in from his
clients with thank you saying how Paul's
visit that day brought them the hope
they needed in a moment of uncertainty
and despair because of Paul they knew
they were not alone and forgotten and
that hope led them to take their first
steps from finding a tarp for their roof
to picking fruit from a nearby tree to
pool with their neighbors or finally
just having the confidence to tell their
children that everything was going to be
okay Paul had a ripple effect and when
the stories of him and others like him
who took small such that day started to
roll in things started to move at my
organization one of our senior
executives started emailing and calling
all of our 900 plus employees a small
group of colleagues showed up to our
central office building the next day and
started salvaging what they could and I
finally showered and left my house for
the first time in three days we went on
to accomplish more than I ever could
have imagined in the weeks and months
following the earthquake I have thought
a lot about what Paul did that day I
think about the fear and paralysis that
I felt and I think about the strength
and courage that he demonstrated and I
wonder what did he know that I didn't
how did he find the strength and courage
he needed to take action in that moment
so one day I asked him and he responded
chipa chipa madam step by step madam
he knew he needed to do something he
decided on a path and then he took it
step by step and one door led to two
which led to three and things started to
spread now this expression t pas ce pas
it hearing it from Paul was not the
first time i heard it actually growing
up with a haitian father I remember
numerous times when I was facing an
obstacle or struggle he would tell me ce
pas ce pas Natalie step by step and then
I think about my mother who's
french-canadian and when she was
struggling with learning English and her
mother would tell her Fitzie opted see
step by step and then my husband news
from Senegal when he was coaching his
friend who is going through a difficult
time he is an expression in his native
language donka donk or step by step
across continents and cultures
everywhere I've looked I found this
unifying theme of using the concept of
step by step to get through a difficult
time so what did Paul do Paul took an
age old notion a universal piece of
wisdom and he put it into practice in a
powerful way because Paul knew taking
things step by step is the only way to
get things done so why is this important
to us here today I've had conversations
with many of you in this room who want
to solve problems or change a situation
and sometimes we feel overwhelmed we're
not sure where to start or which path to
take we worried about the impact will
have and we get stuck so I ask you
when's the last time you felt
overwhelmed by a situation for me it was
this past January 12th on the four year
anniversary of the earthquake well I was
proud of the things we accomplished
through news reports in
conversations with friends I was made
aware that there's still a lot of work
left to do and I was wondering what can
I do from here and those knots and my
stomach started to come back and then I
remembered Paul and I took my first step
I sent an email and that email turned
into one then three then five and more
of our classmates signing up to join me
on a trip to Haiti this spring break and
this trip will be their first steps in
understanding and learning about the
opportunities and obstacles that Haiti
faces so for me the first steps was an
email for the aspiring entrepreneur
who's sitting on an idea take your first
steps make that phone call share your
idea for the aspiring runner who's
wanting to get ready for the next big
race take your first step and put on
your running shoes for the new parents
who are worried if they're gonna do a
good job take your first step and
believe that you will so I ask of you
the next time you are feeling
overwhelmed remember tipa tipa and let
this wisdom of step-by-step take you
through it because overcoming life's
challenges can be as easy as taking a
single step
you